-Guys, we're in the middle
of the NFL season
and this Sunday night's game has
the Los Angeles Chargers
facing off against the
Pittsburgh Steelers.
-Whoo!
-Now, as you know,
at the end of every season,
they give out awards,
like Most Valuable Player,
but they also give out awards
during the season.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time
for "Tonight Show Superlatives."
Here we go.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ Tonight Show ♪
♪ Superlatives ♪
♪♪
-Our first player is
from the Steelers. It's...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow!
-Medium, large, tire hole.
Next up from the Steelers is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter ]
Next up from the Chargers is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter ]
Next up from the Chargers is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter ]
"That's what's up."
Next up from the Chargers is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up from the Chargers is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter ]
He got an award for that.
-Yeah, he got an award.
What is that?
-It's very rare.
-Very rare.
-They rarely give that out.
-Wow.
-Next up from the Chargers is...
-Storm.
-He was voted...
[ Laughter ]
"Now, the weather
with Storm Norton."
[ Laughter ]
Next up from the Steelers is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Bit much.
Next up from the Steelers is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter ]
[ Surfer voice ]
Almonds. Good choice.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Surfer voice ]
These are back in stock.
Nice!
-Oh, these are back in stock?
You got to be kidding me.
Right on.
-Sweet!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Wait, I'm gonna go get some.
-I'm gonna get some
and I'm gonna try them
right in front of you.
[ Laughter ]
We'll eat almonds together.
[ Fresh laughter ]
Noice, noice, noice!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Freshly squeezed juice?
Noice!
Juice is noice!
[ Laughter ]
Can you agree with me on that,
juice is noice?
[ Laughter ]
Finally, from the Chargers is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you have it.
Those are your "Superlatives."